Збір врожаю у розпалі - а ця несправна техніка
посеред села Лозовий Яр на Яготинщині простоює.
От цей, подивіться. А то він кожен день пик-пшик. Почистимо.
Фермер Анатолій Бойко зі своїми друзями - теж фермерами –
нервують, адже треба встигнути, поки ще гарна погода.
Але ще більше нервують через погані, як вони вважають, новини з Києва.
Верховна Рада готується ухвалитизакон про
скасування мораторію на продаж землі сільгосппризначення.
І державної, і пайової.
Планується, що землю можна буде продавати на аукціонах.
Для Анатолія це великий ризик.
Він боїться, щовтратить можливість обробляти
близько 450 гектарів землі, які вже багато років орендує у держави.
Вони кажуть, що ми все це скасовуємо і державні землі йдуть на аукціон.
Одразу! Але як на аукціон? Я її уже 20 років обробляю.
І я її не віддам. Хай вони там навіть 100 аукціонів проведуть!
Вони можуть забрати землю, хіба якщо мене вб’ють.
Уряд тим часом намагається переконати фермерів,
що нервувати не варто, мовляв, впроваджуються
більш цивілізовані земельні відносини.
Земельні аукціони з оренди та продажу землі
відбуватимуться через систему "Прозоро".
Таким чином хочуть вивести частину агарного бізнесу з тіні.
Держава обіцяє українським фермерам,
які орендують землі, що саме вони матимуть
першочергове право викупу або оренди.
Однак фермери в це не вірять.
Ніхто не спроможний з нас, українців, купити землю фінансово.
У нас немає стільки грошей. Зараз буде конкуренція,
і вони задавлять. Європа - не Європа. Азія давить,
скуплять всю землю. Вони такі - гроші мішками возять.
Я таких грошей у житті не бачив.
Михайло та Анатолій побоюються, що з відкриттям ринку землі
вони втратять свій "хліб", бо фермерство в Україні
стане доступним громадянам інших держав,
які, приміром, мають можливість отримати кредити
на бізнес у банках своїх країн за набагато меншими
відсотковими ставками, ніж українські 20 відсотків.
Аграрні союзи та фермерські асоціації на зустрічі
з профільним міністром Тимофієм Миловановим
напряму запитують його про гарантії, що відкриття земельного ринку не призведе
до появи великої кількості власників з іноземними паспортами
або їхніх представників з українськими паспортами,
що може спричинити знищення вітчизняних
маленьких фермерських господарств.
Розмова не про те, як правильно, чи-то іноземці погані чи хороші.
Розмова про те, хто буде платити вищі зарплати,
хто буде забезпечувати ті культури, які потрібні для продуктової безпеки
і хто буде мати більше робочих місць.
Я хочу, щоб у селі люди сьогодні працювали.
Міністр обіцяє підтримку фермерам - з обмовкою,
що їм треба буде показати результат.
Однак аграріїв це не заспокоює - вони ставлять питання руба.
Ви наш міністр економіки чи іноземний?
Я наш міністр економіки.
Ви маєте в наших інтересах працювати!
Не уваших, я перепрошую, а в інтересах держави.
Ні, я буду працювати в інтересах всіх громадян України!
Міністр Милованов не витримує зливи запитань -
його вистачає лише на 10 хвилин.
Меседж міністра - уряд прагне не розпродати землі,
а створити ефективний ринок землі, який сприятиме
зростанню ВВП і розвитку сільських громад.
Анатолій Бойко каже, що не може спокійно це слухати.
Він господарює на землі більш ніж 20 років,
бачив, як різні президенти намагалися вже разів десять
скасувати мораторій на продаж земель і впроваджували різні моделі.
Нинішню модель теж вважає недосконалою.
Не спішить, не біжіть!
Ви там 10 законів у день голосуєте і не знаєте, за що голосуєте…
Зробіть земельний банк, підтягуйте туди кошти.
Хоче людина купити - ось, земельний банк викупляє цю діляночку.
І тоді на правах оренди надає тій людині, яка тут живе і працює.
Уряд, за словами Милованова, продажем землі займатися не буде,
а ці функції передадуть місцевому самоврядуванню.
Згідно із законопроектом, територіальним громадам
можуть віддати до 9 мільйонів гектарів земель.
Представники фермерських асоціацій вважають це
дуже ризикованим - з огляду на корупцію.
Цей законопроект дозволяє викупити всю землю
в межах села, територіальної громади, ОТГ -
підкреслюю, всю землю на одну юридичну особу.
Ось цього обмеження в проекті немає. А це означатиме,
що власник цієї землі отримує фактично політичну владу,
тому що він буде єдиним великим роботодавцем,
і місцева влада буде в нього на підряді.
Бабця Олена з села Лозовий Яр разом з донькою
має у власності земельні пАї, які здають в оренду.
Отримують щороку понад триста доларів, тонну зерна,
інколи безкоштовну техніку для побутових потреб.
Жінки вважають, що реформа робиться поспіхом -
уряд хоче відкрити ринок з жовтня2020.
Це їм нагадало часи, коли робітникам державних підприємств
спочатку роздали ваучери, а потім задешево скупили.
Не треба її продавати. Треба, щоб наші діти росли,
щоб вони обробляли, щоб вони працювали на нашій землі.
Я в оренду здала, якусь копійку маю. А продати?
Дадуть мені… що вони там мені дадуть?
За рік витрачу все, а тоді зуби на полицю - ті, що немає…
Я і так важко добивалися, робила на тій фермі, рано прокидалася.
А тепер землю продам? То треба зовсім безголовим бути!
Уряд запевняє, що відкриття земельного ринку -
це кількарічний процес і поспіхом продавати нічого не будуть.
Варто зачекати, коли земля подорожчає, коли
в агарний сектор прийде більше інвестицій,
коли держава створить для фермерів фонди
підтримки і прийнятні умови кредитування.
Але фермера Анатолія це не переконує.
Та не треба нам ні кредитів, ні фондів, нам нічого не треба.
Ви просто нас не чіпайте, не "кошмарте", не лізьте до нас сюди.
Ми без вас розберемося. Ми виростим хліб і до хліба вам принесемо.
Анатолій не проти вільного і прозорого ринку землі.
Але переконаний, що Україні треба до цього ще кілька років готуватися.
Фермери Яготинського району на Київщині
ініціювали звернення місцевої райради з вимогою
не скасовувати мораторій на продаж землі
і провести референдум на цю тему.
Вони не розуміють, чому влада не виходить
на розмову з простими робітниками полів.
Президента вже кликали на свій з’їзд у вересні, та не дочекалися.
Кажуть, що якщо далі так піде, то вийдуть протестувати.